it's almost as
old as the universe and as massive
as 34 billion suns
it eats stars for breakfast
and now it's about to consume ours
[Music]
behold the great and powerful black hole
with the catchy name j2157
if it came close enough to our solar
system
how fast would it destroy us
how would it all go sideways for our sun
and how exactly would this monstrous
black hole
end all life on earth
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if a black hole swallowed the sun
black holes are scary enough they form
when
big stars explode in a supernova
and then collapse in on themselves
the most common black holes the stellar
ones
are only 16 kilometers in diameter but
they have the mass of a star at least 10
times more massive
than our sun crammed in them
all that mass compressed into such a
small diameter
makes black holes extremely dense
if you came too close to a black hole's
vicinity
beyond its event horizon its extreme
gravitational pull
would turn you into a spaghetti noodle
but there are black holes so massive
that
they make stellar black holes look
feather light
these are called super massive black
holes
these monstrosities lurk at the centers
of galaxies
and take up space roughly the size of
our solar system
but most of them don't even get close to
the size
of black hole j2157
j2157 is the fastest growing black hole
in the known universe and it's the
second largest one
its event horizon has a radius of 670
astronomical units which is comparable
to the distance between
the sun and neptune multiplied by 22.
whoa if that's not scary enough
j2157 holds the title of the hungriest
black hole we know
to stay in good shape it gobbles up
matter at a rate
of about one sun per day
now take this monstrosity and bring it
closer to
our solar system you can imagine how
that would play out
if j2157 could replace the supermassive
black hole
that sits at the center of our milky way
galaxy
to us on earth it would look 10 times
brighter than
the full moon that's because of its
incredibly large
accretion disk the matter the black hole
collected
on its way to us and because it always
needs to be the center of attention
this monstrous black hole would outshine
most of the stars in the sky
if a black hole under 100 million masses
of our sun
entered our solar system it wouldn't
swallow the sun in one go
it would gradually start pulling matter
from our star
until all that's left of it would be a
cloud of gas
in that case you could expect lethal
amounts of cosmic radiation headed
toward the earth
but that's not how j2157 likes to deal
with things
a black hole of that size and mass would
devour the sun
in a moment but losing the sun
would be the least of our problems
our planet could be torn apart by the
tidal forces
from the black hole consuming our sun or
it could be bombarded with an
unthinkable amount of cosmic radiation
or it would disappear into the black
hole's event horizon
along with the rest of the solar system
either way
you wouldn't get out of this alive but
no matter how big and scary j2157
is remember that it sits at a safe
distance
of 12 and a half billion light years
away from us
i'd say we're pretty safe here
now if you ever plan to visit a black
hole
you'll need to look into some survival
tips
and we have a new show for you about
just that
to help you survive whatever awaits you
you